okay let's start a new game with a song
player from Sweden obviously a fan of
American Grandmaster yessir Sarah one
also go for the exchange line here case
plane c 6 which is some may be the most
solid move Mariana now come we are
racing to recently i played this I think
against Carlton getting the bishop to g6
not quite sure how this game went but i
think carlton um went for long castle
here 9 a-6 yeah this is of course an
idea get the night to be four maybe
yeah I want to take the a foursquare I
no control or not before I can go to d2
ok 92 and I need to get something going
on the kingside quickly i think pledge
form i might want to play up to d6 ok
but i still have g five then and then h5
okay let's try this
yeah I think I need to spend the temple
know a to maybe a night before I can
also go to be three so the questions and
should i play h5 or not and not sure ok
I think need to act quickly even already
somewhat down on time yeah of course you
could play this bit but take on g6 takes
g5 take an f7 this is not enough most
likely
so difficult need to be quick here maybe
even a form let's try out for okay III
is hanging but I'm threatening on g6 now
okay think objectively this position
should be quite good for black of term
okay now is threatening on a two I think
should i take g6
hmm check
I need to get the Ice King somewhere
maybe queen to d7 something 2076
something like this
and you're 27 not sure what should you
do maybe I also threatened taking on see
695 simply no idea very complicated for
instance queen d 8 or something i think
i can take c6 this should be should be
okay now okay time warning
if I simply every take this it's got 22
okay Queenie 8 mate basically this is
the threat I'm not sure I don't see
anything else I'm 22 and then take on e
to not sure then ok I can give a check
here but he's got just King our seven
maybe I need to take on d6 get rid of a
bishop check check
complicated Geoff watches Cytron maybe
check check check check check check
check check
check check wrong wrong yeah only got 17
seconds left so not the right spot for
some fancy winning tries okay maybe it's
just perpetual anyway yeah it tells me
terrible game f at least it was very
complicated hard to tell ya if it was
certainly good for like at some point
but not sure it was so clear cut
how nice is insulting me a little bit
I've well whatever now thought night a 2
here would be it would be an idea have
to take with the Queen I think I'll move
the King not sure this is so even
possible yeah it was certainly good for
like at some point cutter by now very
difficult ok let's sum due to the next
game I hope I get this guy once again